bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant la séance de questions
cribles en direct de l'hémicycle les
questions créé vous le savez ce sont des
questions très précises que les
sénateurs pause sur un sujet précis un
ministre aujourd'hui ces questions sont
consacrés à la rentrée universitaire et
c'est donc la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
geneviève fioraso qui répondent très
bonne séance et au sein d'une minute au
maximum peut être présentés soit par
l'auteur de la question soit par l'un
des membres de son groupe politique
la parole est à monsieur robert tropéano
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen deux
minutes chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
évoquer aujourd'hui le dossier de
l'université montpellier iii et
l'annoncera possible fermeture de son
antenne située à béziers lors de la
prochaine rentrée universitaire cette
fermeture et menacerait et 700 étudiants
qui la fréquentent pour les huit
formations qui sont dispensés autant
dire que l'application d'une telle
décision fragiliserait l' équilibre
territorial de l'ouest héraultais
l'université de montpellier iii se
trouve dans une situation financière
difficile
accusant un déficit structurel de 3
millions d'euros
depuis la loi relative aux libertés et
responsabilités des universités le
transfert de la masse salariale qui
représente 90 % des budgets des
établissements s'est opérée de manière
brutale
aujourd'hui plusieurs universités vous
disent qu'elles sont en déficit et la
situation de montpellier iii n'est donc
pas un cas isolé
la sous-estimation de la masse salariale
fait à l'époque de la mise en place de
cette réforme et l'augmentation de
saint-élie % 50 des étudiants pour
boursiers sont des facteurs déterminants
dans les difficultés rencontrées compte
tenu des engagements forts pris par le
président de la république en faveur de
la jeunesse et des récentes déclarations
que vous avez faite sur le maillage des
pôles universitaires
implanté dans 10 villes moyennes il est
inconcevable que cette décision de
fermeture puis
être actée n'avez vous pas dit lors d'un
récent déplacement
nous voulons des universités qui sont
toutes performantes chacune à sa manière
et qui offre des formations de proximité
d'un très bon niveau de qualité pour
tous nos jeunes toute la communauté
éducative tous les étudiants de la
région mais également des collectivités
territoriales qui ont consenti des
efforts importants attendent vos
décisions sur ce dossier
ainsi madame la ministre comme vous le
soulignez très justement toute réforme
nécessite concertation et elle ne fut
pas le cas lors de la mise en place de
la réforme portant sur l'autonomie des
universités
aussi je souhaiterais savoir si vous
pouviez nous informer des premiers
éléments de diagnostic sur l'audit qui
est actuellement réalisé et connaître
les dispositions que vous entendez
prendre pour assurer la pérennité de
l'antenne universitaire de vizille il
convient d'apporter une réponse est non
seulement aux étudiants mais également
et à madame la présidente montpellier
iii qui lors d'une réunion à bazire
fustigé l'attitude du gouvernement en
déclarant que les chiffres donnés par
les ministères sont faux ce que je nos
premières si cher collègue madame
geneviève fioraso lise l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le sénateur pour votre question
qui va me permettre de faire le point
sur ce dossier qui effectivement fait
beaucoup parler de lui au niveau
médiatique mais c'est pas ça qui nous
intéresse qui nous intéresse est la
situation réelle des universités au
moment du passage en rce c'est à dire au
moment du passage réel à l'autonomie un
certain nombre d'universités qui sont
passées à l'autonomie entre 2008 et 2012
sont effectivement aujourd'hui en
difficulté pas tout
elles sont en difficulté notamment la
première année du passage aux rce
pourquoi parce qu'en général les
universités dans leur mode de
comptabilité ne tenait pas compte des
dotations aux amortissements celles ci
sont nécessaires au moment du passage en
6e donc cela fait une année
effectivement difficile que les
prédécesseurs n'avaient ni préparée ni
anticiper ni accompagné que nous nous
sommes engagés à accompagner en ce qui
concerne mont pellier j'ai appris comme
vous par la presse avec un déficit de 3
millions d'euros était envisagée alors
même que l'on nous
annoncé il ya quelques mois un solde
positif donc j'ai été étonné j'ai appris
aussi comme vous par la presse que le
conseil d'administration envisagé de
fermer l'antenne de béziers au mois de
septembre pour la rentrée de 2014
je me suis exprimé à plusieurs reprises
en faveur des pôles non pas secondaire
je refuse de l'appliquer de les appeler
ainsi mais des pôles de proximité parce
qu'ils accueillent davantage d'étudiants
boursiers
parce qu'ils ont un taux de réussite et
d'insertion professionnelle important et
parce qu'ils permettent à des jeunes qui
ne peuvent pas aller en métropole pour
des raisons financières de poursuivre
des études
c'est pourquoi j'ai comme j'ai
commandité aussitôt un audit sur place
dont je n'ai pas les résultats je ne
veux donc pas m'aventurer à vous
communiquer des résultats partiels alors
même que je n'ai pas les résultats
mais il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
qui doivent être explicités car il faut
expliquer pourquoi on est passé d'une
prévision positive à un résultat
prévisionnels encore une fois négatif
dans tous les cas de figure le ministère
s'engage à accompagner l'université de
montpellier iii
mais il faut être deux pour être
accompagné je souhaite que nous soyons
deux interlocuteurs c'est à dire qu'il
faut que nous travaillons ensemble
il faut absolument au bénéfice des
étudiants des familles que nous sortions
ensemble positivement de cette situation
aujourd'hui bloquée merci monsieur
pernaut 1 minute de riposte
oui merci monsieur le président la
ministre merci de votre réponse et de
votre engagement
je sais que vous mettez tout en oeuvre
pour sauvegarder l'avenir de cette
annexe du week-end à béziers et ce dans
un climat se règle et responsable que
vous attendez institué la réponse était
sereine deuxième question la parole est
à mme colette mélot pour le mou voire
ump merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre michelle que l'aig
ma question portera sur les conditions
de vie étudiante et notamment sur
l'accès des étudiants un logement selon
deux enquêtes récentes distincte de
l'unef et de la fage le coût de la
rentrée étudiante a augmenté de 1,6 pour
cent par rapport à l'année dernière
le logement représente le principal
poste de dépense en moyenne 500 euros
par mois en région et 700
euros en ile-de-france soit 55 % du
budget total des étudiants les étudiants
sont de temps sont donc de plus en plus
nombreux à devoir travailler pour
financer leurs études
et cela au détriment de leur parcours
universitaire face à l'absence de
revalorisation des aides au logement
l'accès à un logement privé devient de
plus en plus difficile pour la majorité
des étudiants du fait des loyers élevés
auxquels il convient de rajouter les
charges locatives et prendre en compte
les augmentations d'électricité ou de
gaz
d'autre part les logements sociaux
destinés aux étudiants sont en nombre
insuffisant
je souhaiterais donc connaître les
mesures que vous comptez prendre
concernant les logements sociaux
le président de la république s'était
engagé sur un objectif précis de
construction de quarante mille logements
d'ici 2017
comment cet engagement se traduira-t-il
précisément dans la loi de finances 2014
je tiens à préciser que sur ce sujet des
associations étudiantes ont rappelé que
les 20 millions d'euros accordés au
cnous pour ses projets de logements ne
suffiront pas à dynamiser la
construction de logements sociaux
concernant le parc privé certaines
agences immobilières requiert un nombre
très important de pièces à fournir tant
par l'étudiant lui-même que par les
garants qui se voit réclamer des avis
d'imposition des bulletins de salaires
et autres justificatifs
vous venez de mettre en place pour la
rentrée 2013 un dispositif national de
cautionnement solidaire son annonce il
en était tardive et le public visé étant
particulièrement restreint étudiant issu
d'une famille monoparentale étudiants
isolés étrangers
pourriez-vous nous dire madame la
ministre combien de personnes seront
finalement concernés comptez-vous par la
suite élargir ce dispositif à l'ensemble
des étudiants puisqu'ils sont finalement
tous concernés par les difficultés
d'accès au logement
merci merci cher collègue madame la
ministre
ce président merci madame la sénatrice
de cette question puisque vous savez que
la réussite étudiante est au coeur des
priorités de ce gouvernement et de la
loi de son enseignement supérieur et la
recherche qui était votée en juillet
dernier et nous savons bien les
conditions de vie en particulier les
conditions de logement compte pour
beaucoup dans la réussite des étudiants
alors vous l'avez dit il représente le
coût des loyers représentent 55% du
budget des étudiants en région à paris
il peut atteindre jusqu'à 70 %
autrement dit un étudiant n'a plus que
peu d'argent pour se nourrir avoir accès
à la culture avoir accès à la santé
faire du sport bref faire tout ce qui
contribue à faire réussir les études
allant dans les dix dernières années le
plan sio avait prévu soixante dix mille
habitations et 50000 construction ce qui
a été réalisé entre 2007 et 2012 par
rapport à ce plan ce serait à peu près
la moitié 36000 réhabilitation mais
beaucoup moins pour les constructions il
y en a eu que 10 9 me le président de la
république m'a fixé une feuille de route
effectivement ambitieuse de quarante
mille logements sur cinq ans nous en
avons déjà identifié à la suite d'une
mission confiée à un préfet m'a prévost
nous en avons identifié 30000 dans le
cadre des plans campus que nous avons
débloqué en fluidifiant et en
diversifiant les procédures en sortant
du tout ppp eu des contrats de projets
etat-régions que nous relançons et enfin
du levier supplémentaire que nous avons
donnée au cnous ce n'est pas seulement
20 millions d'euros c'est 20 millions
d'euros de plus par rapport aux 70
millions d'euros précédent que le cnous
a obtenu par notre augmentation du
budget nous avons augmenté de 7% la vie
étudiante nous avons également dégager
400 millions d'euros de nouveau pour les
bourses sur trois ans c'est un effort
historique
c'est ce qu'ont dit les présidents des
organisations d'étudiants et vous savez
qu'ils ne sont souvent pas tendre et qui
sont à juste titre assez exigeant dont
400 millions d'euros de plus sur trois
ans c'est un premier pas vers la
location d'études que nous nous sommes
engagés à mettre en place sur les cinq
ans donc des efforts sur le logement des
efforts sur les revenus des étudiants
pour leur permettre notamment de
travailler moins parce qu'on sait qu'au
delà de quinze heures par semaine il met
en danger leurs études
et tout cela devrait contribuer
fortement à la réussite des étudiants
nous avons livré dès cette rentrée de
septembre
huit mille cinq cents logements la
moitié en réhabilitation la moitié en
construction merci madame
ministre madame mélo l'amérique
merci monsieur le président merci madame
la ministre pour les précisions que vous
devez que vous venez de me donner
nous ne manquerons pas à l'avenir de
faire de faire un nouveau bilan mais
concernant le cautionnement solidaire
une priorité est fixé pour les personnes
ayant des difficultés à trouver un
cautionnement
mais le problème est étudiant vient
également du manque de confiance des
propriétaires dans la caution proposée
par les étudiants d'où la nécessité
d'élargir le dispositif pour que l'état
soit garant pour tous sinon une
inégalité sera créé pour les étudiants
ayant une caution ordinaire est pas une
caution d'état je vous remercie le
prendre en compte
merci chaque collègue la parole à madame
chantal jouanno pour le groupe u10 uc
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues d'une
question qui tient à coeur à monsieur
dupont à mon collègue monsieur dupont
sur la situation financière des
universités dont il est difficile de se
faire une idée claire le gouvernement se
veut rassurant il est tout à fait dans
son rôle en annonçant que 5000 postes
universitaires sur le quinquennat
devrait être créé que la loi du 23
juillet dernier a redéfini les missions
d'enseignement supérieur et que le
budget de la mission interministérielle
de recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
la mairesse augmentera de 0 44% par
rapport à 2013 et pourtant les syndicats
tentent étudiants qu enseignants et
chercheurs s'alarme vous dire et ils
sont aussi dans leur rôle par contre
quand la présidente de l'université de
montpellier ferme le site de béziers
pour protester contre sa dot sa dotation
budgétaire pardon elle n'est sans doute
pas totalement dans son rôle de fait la
situation budgétaire des établissements
semble toujours très préoccupante
toujours 15 universités sur 76 devrait
être en déficit cette année trois
d'entre elles sont dans une situation
critique et 38 autres avons un fonds de
roulement inférieur au seuil de sécurité
alors on peut se demander si les mesures
prises sont à la hauteur des enjeux que
je viens d'évoquer
d'une part le budget des créations de
postes servirait en fait à couvrir les
besoins de financement des
établissements et de fait les présidents
d'université annonce le gel de 400
postes soit 40 pour cent des 1000 postes
promis d'autre part une fois que
l'inflation est prise en compte
le budget de la mission b serait en
réalité de 0 46% et encore le glissement
vieillesse technicité n'est pas encore
répercuté dans le budget des universités
madame la ministre comment entendez-vous
concrétiser votre détermination à je
cite remettre l'université et la
recherche en mouvement merci madame la
ministre monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice merci à nouveau de cette
question effectivement moi même j'ai
beaucoup de mal et j'ai mis un certain
temps avant de d'avoir des idées plus
claires sur la situation réelle des
universités pourquoi parce qu'elles ne
sont pas toutes passées en rce c'est à
dire alors non pas l'autonomie parce
qu'elles le sont depuis leur création
autonome mais elles n'ont pas opéré la
déconcentration des fonds tout à la même
période
ce que l'on observe c'est que je les dis
dans l'année ou dans les deux ans qui
suivent ce passage aux rce
les universités sont confrontés à des
difficultés parce que il leur faut
prouveront provisionner des dotations
aux amortissements ce qu'elle ne faisait
pas auparavant mais aussi parce qu'elles
n'ont pas été accompagnées à sedan ce
passage et qui ont leurs conseillers au
contraire une ce sont mes prédécesseurs
qui le faisait on leurs conseillers eux
de saturer les postes or aucune
administration aucun organisme ne
saturent complètement ces postes c'est
ainsi que dans certaines universités de
taille moyenne il y a eu 98 embauches au
moment du passage en rce cela permettait
de passer plus facilement en rce
simplement ensuite quand vous avez 98
postes à temps plein financées bas
effectivement ça ça cause des
difficultés dans n'importe quelle
entreprise lorsque vous multipliez
artificiellement certain budget par 10
sans accompagner les gestionnaires sans
accompagner la gouvernance est bien en
général sur son entreprise va dans le
mur tout simplement nous n'allons pas
normes sûrs parce que nous provision
toujours 90 % du budget des universités
c'est la masse salariale et sur les 10%
restants effectivement c'est plus
difficile pour les universités d'autant
qu'au moment
du transfert du passage aux rce le gvt
le glissement vieillissement technicité
n'a pas été prise en compte dans le
transfert donc l'évolution des salaires
pour le dire plus simplement n'a pas été
prises en compte pas plus que
l'augmentation du casse pensions tous
les organismes de recherche paye
eux-mêmes leur gvt ça qu'est ce qui te
même de leur gvt mais ça n'était pas le
cas pour les universités donc nous avons
dû aider les universités ce qu'il
n'avait pas été fait par mes
prédécesseurs au cours de ces deux
dernières années et nous les
accompagnons avec l'ingénierie
spécifique pour les amener par exemple à
davantage rassembler leurs offres de
formation parce que 10000 master 3800
licence et peut-être beaucoup sans pour
autant porter atteinte à ce que ce
qu'est notre priorité et qui est la
réussite étudiante c'est un exercice
difficile mais nous avons trouvé une
situation dégradée et nous faisons de
notre mieux et je vais donner une image
positive des universités françaises qui
sont de très bonne qualité
merci à la ministre madame jouanno c'est
pas obligatoire chaque année c'est pas
obligatoire je remercie la ministre je
pense qu'elle est tout à fait dans ce
rôle et je transmettrai à des personnes
compétentes votre réponse merci la
parole est à dominique gillot pour le
groupe socialiste président madame la
ministre
malgré les ambitions affichées par le
précédent gouvernement dans le cadre du
plan réussite en licence les indicateurs
de nous dont nous disposons témoigne
aujourd'hui d'une dégradation de la
situation
la loi et sert promulguée en juillet
dernier et riche cet enjeu essentiel de
la réussite étudiante en 1ère objectifs
du service public de l'enseignement
supérieur cette volonté que nous
partageons tous doit d'abord se traduire
par l'affirmation d'une continuité entre
l'enseignement secondaire et
l'enseignement supérieur et la celle
d'une affirmation aussi d'une pédagogie
attentive révisé compléter les missions
du premier cycle pour garantir à tout
étudiant la constitution d'un projet
personnel et professionnel lui
permettent de comprendre ce qu'il peut
attendre l'université ce que
l'université attend de lui introduire la
spécialisation progressive en premier
cycle en élargissant la
pluridisciplinarité des enseignements
dispensés en licence avec les appuis du
ministère la mise en oeuvre de la loi
est en cours
éclairant les initiatives de certaines
universités qui se sont déjà engagés
dans la réussite de leurs étudiants
c'est le cas à cergy-pontoise que je
connais bien sous l'impulsion de son
président l'université
assumant sa responsabilité sociale a mis
en place un semestre nouveau départ
permettant aux étudiants de se
réorienter positivement en cours d'année
madame la ministre de quel outil
disposez-vous pour accélérer la mise en
oeuvre de ce processus qui doit aussi
mobiliser le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
depuis cette année il est mis fin à
l'injustice qui frappait les bacheliers
professionnels et technologiques
il bénéficie maintenant d'un excès plus
aisés ou sts et iut au moyen d'un
pourcentage minimaux fixés par un pour
ces filières avez-vous des indicateurs
sur les effets de cette disposition qui
a fait grand bruit
enfin pour faire entrer l'université
dans le 21e siècle et préparer la france
de demain vous soutenez le développement
du numérique dans l'enseignement
supérieur
amorçant ainsi la révolution pédagogique
attendue par les étudiants et les
enseignants accompagnés de moyens
financiers et techniques importants le
lancement de la plateforme nationale fun
permettra à notre pays de rattraper son
retard dans ce domaine
madame la ministre de l'ap pourriez vous
nous préciser les prochaines actions
concrètes en faveur de la réussite
étudiante maintenant le ministre merci
chat collègues
merci de votre question de la menace n'a
tri cela la réussite étudiante et est
effectivement aucun des priorités du
gouvernement pourquoi parce que nous
sommes plus de 10 % en deçà de
l'objectif de lisbonne qui est de former
50 % des jeunes de ces pays européens à
niveau bac + 3 il est diplômé un niveau
bac + 3 nous sommes en dessous de 40%
est bien en dessous même si l'on exclut
les dut les bts il nous faut donc
rattraper ce retard parce que si nous
voulons une société innovante avec d une
industrie qui se redresse
il nous faut augmenter également la
qualification de notre jeunesse
alors en fait les étudiants finalement
arrive à saint céré assez bien mais ils
ont trop souvent un parcours erratique
ce parcours erratique et préjudiciable
aux étudiants dans les familles ont des
revenus modestes c'est ce qui se passe
en france et la situation
donc nous pouvons
agir avec les universités dans les
dotations qui leur sont versés nous
sommes mis d'accord avec les conférences
des présidents d université pour que les
dotations contractuels qui soient versés
aux universités tiennent compte de la
priorité réussite en licence de façon à
éviter la situation précédente ou 730
millions de plants licence avait réussi
à faire reculer de 5 points la réussite
en licence en trois ans nous avons donc
un certain nombre de critères comme
l'accompagnement des étudiants en
difficulté en première année une
orientation qu'on appelle moins trois
plus trois en lien avec le ministère
d'éducation nationale un comité sup
l'emploi qui réunira des chefs
d'entreprise et cadres d'entreprises des
formateurs et des universitaires pour
mieux anticiper sur les filières
porteuses et sur les nouveaux métiers
également l'introduction du numérique
non pas comme un gadget mais comme outil
pédagogique innovant au service de la
réussite étudiante en rendant davantage
actifs les étudiants dans leur parcours
étudiant nous avons déjà reçu 53 contrat
pédagogique des universités pour
qu'elles puissent bénéficier de ces
dotations spécifiques et sur critères
qualitatifs
c'est donc un objectif de réussite en
licence avec de l'innovation pédagogique
avec le doublement de l'alternance avec
une pédagogie qui mise sur un
accompagnement personnalisé et efficace
qui se met en place et qui met
effectivement les universités en
mouvement merci madame si l'on ne
souhaite pas la parole
si oui merci madame la ministre pour
cette précision a c'est vrai que
l'exercice est très rapide mais je pense
qu'à travers toutes vos réponses on a
trouvé les éléments qui vont nous
permettre d'appuyer la mise en oeuvre de
la loi
merci madame brigitte gonthier maurin
pour le groupe crc citoyens merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues la lru de 2007 et le
passage aux responsabilités et
compétences élargies de 2008
mis en place par le précédent
gouvernement on plaçait les universités
en situation de grande difficulté
l'autonomie a essentiellement consisté
en un transfert de la gestion de la
pénurie budgétaire de l'état vers les
universités devenues vecteur
d'application de la rgpp dans
l'enseignement supérieur
ces dispositions n'ont pas à ce jour été
fondamentalement remise en cause
il est d'ailleurs caucase d'entendre
ceux qui en sont les auteurs s'en
émouvoir aujourd'hui nulle surprise donc
à ce que cette année encore la rentrée
universitaire soit très compliqué 15
universités sur 76 sont en déficit les
autres universités n'atteignent
l'équilibré budgétaire qu'au prix de
mesures d'économies d'économies aussi
drastiques que dangereuse diminution du
fonds de roulement inférieur aux 30
jours réglementaires gel de postes et
non revenir renouvellement de cdd vous
avancez la création de 1000 postes par
an mais comment s'en féliciter quand il
ne compenseront même pas le gel des
emplois demi depuis 2008 et que 500 gel
d'emplois viennent s'y ajouter pour 2014
comment y voir une avancée alors que le
budget 2014 ne finance toujours pas le
gvt qui augmente mécaniquement chaque
année le coût de la masse salariale des
établissements
la situation est si grave que certaines
universités devront utiliser l'argent de
ces postes pour payer des frais de
fonctionnement aussi élémentaires que le
chauffage que la faiblesse des dotations
de l'état ne permettent plus d'assurer
conséquence les conditions d'étude se
dégrade pour les étudiants heures
d'enseignement mutualisé ou supprimées
capacité d'accueil limitée vous ouvrant
la voie à une sélection injuste
formation fermer quand ce ne sont pas
des sites entiers
aussi madame la ministre voudrait vous
demandez quelle mesure vous comptez
prendre pour qu'enfin la rentrée
universitaire se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions
merci madame la ministre merci madame la
sénatrice genevois pour les universités
ni la vie en rose ni la vie en noir
c'est à dire que la situation que j'ai
trouvé en arrivant en 2012 à ce
ministère est effectivement une
situation difficile pour un certain
nombre d'universités pour autant il nous
faut donner une image de l'université
qui soit une image de qualité car
l'enseignement à l'université et de
qualité il ne faudrait pas en demandant
des moyens nouveaux contribuer encore à
déqualifier la représentation que le
souffre et de l'université
l'enseignement l'enseignement
l'enseignement à lui l'enseignement à
l'université
sûrement l'enseignement de plus grande
qualité nous ne supprimons pas des
emplois nous en créons mille par an
pendant cinq ans cela n'avait pas été
fait depuis des années que tous ces
emplois ne soient pas remplies c'est un
fait mais il est prudent ciel de la part
des présidents d'université de ne pas
utiliser tous leurs contingents d'emploi
en début d'année de ne pas saturer les
poches aucune administration
aucun organisme de saturo ces postes par
prudence mais ces emplois sont utilisés
et nous avons toute la liste je la tiens
à votre disposition pour lutter contre
l'échec en premier cycle
alors s'il faut pour cela réduire un peu
le nombre des masters et mutualisée au
profit du premier cycle cela peut être
tout à fait justifié cela ne dégradent
rien dégradera en rien la qualité de
l'enseignement dispensé
mais cela au contraire augmentera les
chances de réussite des étudiants
et c'est cela que nous voulons faire à
l'université c'est dans cet esprit que
nous discutons des universités et je
rappelle que ces 1000 postes sont bien
créés chaque année qu'il ya eu 2 %
d'augmentation du budget de l'année
dernière 1 % d'augmentation de la
dotation et que les difficultés une
porte que sur les 10% du budget puisque
90% du budget c'est du transfert en
réalité de salaire et que ce transfert
pour un complet qu'il soit à cause des
conditions de passage aux rce par mes
prédécesseurs ce cette masse salariale
représente 90 % du budget donc il s'agit
de discuter avec les universités sur les
10% en leur donnant des moyens
complémentaires mais en leur demandant
aussi de s'orienter en direction de la
réussite des étudiants est
particulièrement premier succès ce que
nous faisons tout en gardant la qualité
de la formation la qualité reconnue et
qu'il faut savoir faire connaître de
façon à ce que les étudiants viennent en
toute confiance à l'université merci
cher collègue madame contiennent même à
nice pour votre réponse
malheureusement je crois une divergence
de fond profonde c'est que nous
considérons que les logis les
difficultés fondamentales que
connaissent aujourd'hui les universités
naissent des logiques de lru et de
passages aux universités du aux rce qui
demeure avec des toasts des dotations
d'état aux universités qui continua de
baisser quoique vous
vous indiquez et avec un budget global
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui cette fois cette année
encore est en diminution
si évidemment on tient compte de la de
l'inflation madame la ministre appuyé
sera pas possible je crois de remédier à
la situation dramatique dont on a
témoignages tous les jours sur le
terrain dans l'enseignement supérieur
sans rupture fondamentale avec les
précédentes politiques conduites nice
avec ni sans moyens supplémentaires
suffisants et je voudrais dire que à
l'heure de la mise en place non sans
difficulté des nouvelles écoles
supérieures du professeur à au sein des
universités dispositif si important pour
la revalorisation du métier d'enseignant
et la préparation des enfants
d'aujourd'hui aux défis de demain
il est plus que jamais temps nécessaire
pour l'état d'assumer pleinement ses
responsabilités
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame corinne beau chaud pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues à l'occasion la
rentrée universitaire de 2013 les écoles
supérieures du professorat et de
l'éducation dit s&p ont ouvert leurs
portes
implanté dans chaque académie ces
nouvelles composantes universitaires
formeront les enseignants de la
maternelle à l'université ainsi que les
conseillers principaux d'éducation
c'était un engagement du président de la
république pour revenir sur les
désastres réforme qui avait engendré la
suppression de la formation pédagogique
des enseignants lors de l'examen de la
loi de refondation de l'école de la
république qui a lu avant l'été les
écologistes avaient alerté le
gouvernement sur le risque que la nature
des formations proposées dans le cadre
des master métiers de l'enseignement de
l'éducation et de la formation ne
prennent pas bien en compte les
inflexions souhaité et en reste à des
enseignements strictement disciplinaire
comme vous le savez le parlement et
notamment le sénat avait intégrée par
voie d'amendement des cadres de contenus
spécifiques parcours artistique et
culturelle formation à la résolution non
violente des conflits recours à des
pédagogie coopérative plutôt que la
compétition contenu dispensés par des
intervenants d'horizons variés
universitaire et professeurs de ces
nouvelles espèces mais aussi des
professeurs déjà en activité ou acteurs
de l'éducation populaire
artiste intervenant alors qu'un nombre
croissant d'universités ne parviennent
pas cela a été dit à boucler leur budget
et que des tensions amène parfois des
presses à se déliter l'intégralité du
contenu pédagogique demandée par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale aux
universités pour les sp doit être
garanti par des moyens identifiés afin
que ces écoles ne soit pas une variable
d'ajustement de leur site de
rattachement
madame la ministre les premiers retours
doit vous être parvenu sur le
déroulement de cette rentrée 2013 dans
les sp je souhaiterais savoir si la
volonté du parlement et de la haute
assemblée ont été respectées par
l'ensemble des universités et s'il
subsiste encore des résistances ou des
difficultés dans la mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
président on à l'ama sénatrice mme merci
de cette question parce que je crois que
les espèces sont vraiment au coeur de la
réussite du projet pédagogique que nous
voulons enclencher ce projet nouveau de
la maternelle finalement jusqu'au
doctorat
nous allons avec les sp renouvelée dans
les dix ans à venir le tiers du corps
professoral dire que le tiers du corps
professoral 300 mille enseignants vont
être formés dans dance et sp c'est dire
l'enjeu c'est dire aussi qu'il ne faut
pas attendre tout de cette rentrée les
meilleurs efforts ont été faits pour que
cette rentrée des espèces soit la plus
réussie possible parce que nous pensions
qu'il y avait une urgence les résultats
de plus en plus mauvais en particulier
pour les élèves pour les jeunes issus
des milieux les plus défavorisés nous
pousser à cette urgence
donc nous avons fait cette rentrée non
pas dans l'urgence de façon extrêmement
construite de façon extrêmement
concertée mais il y aura une progression
dans les années à venir sur les sujets
plus précis que vous avez abordé
notamment sur le travail en groupe le
travail en équipe qu'il faut voir se
substituer ou du moins compléter la
performance individuelle sur laquelle
est basée quasiment exclusivement notre
système pédagogique
nous en sommes tout à fait d'accord et
cela est prévu dans les contenus
pédagogiques de la même manière les
gestes professionnels je cite puisque
c'est le sait le texte de la loi liés
aux situations d'apprentissage dont la
conduite de classe et la prévention des
violences scolaires la prise en compte
de la diversité des publics et en
particulier des élèves en situation de
handicap
la méthode de différenciation
pédagogique et de soutien aux élèves en
aide aux élèves en difficulté seront
bien prises en compte
il se trouve que le recteur filâtre qui
connaît bien le sujet puisqu'il a
travaillé lui-même sur les formations
des sp a été missionné avec un homologue
du ministère de l'éducation nationale
edouard leroy poursuivre l'ensemble des
espèces qui se met en place et
poursuivre toutes et tous ces sujets et
toute la diversité des formations
complémentaires à mettre en place qui
sont à la fois académique disciplinaire
vous le savez est professionnel il y a
aujourd'hui 6 sp pour qui ont bénéficié
d'une autorisation provisoire et que
nous suivante la plus grande attention
parce qu'elles connaissent des
difficultés se sont versailles toulouse
grenoble antilles guyane paris et lyon
ces espèces ont suivi de près en
particulier par ses deux chargés de
mission et toutes nos équipes sont
mobilisées pour qu'elles progressent
rapidement et qu'à la rentrée scolaire
prochaine
tout cela soit en ordre de marche au
service encore une fois des parcours de
réussite
merci madame la ministre line beauchamp
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues brièvement je remercie
madame la ministre de la précision de sa
réponse à cette question qui tenait
particulièrement à coeur à madame la
présidente marie blandin juste dire que
nous sommes sur un dossier je dirais
particulièrement symbolique puisqu'il
s'agit de faire travailler de concert
les universités autonomes
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
le ministère de l'enseignement scolaire
le ministère de la culture et toutes les
collectivités territoriales qui ont un
rôle très important sur ces questions et
donc nous espérons avoir régulièrement
des informations sur la mise en place de
ces sp et nous irons d'ailleurs voir sur
le terrain ce que cela donne afin de
rendre compte à nos collègues de ce
dossier très important je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame natacha bouchart pour le groupe
ump
oui madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je souhaite interroger le
gouvernement sur sa politique en matière
de soutien aux formations scientifiques
et techniques mis en place au sein des
universités de proximité dans les
territoires
ma réflexion est inspiré de la situation
de l'ulco l'université du littoral et de
la côte d'opale que je connais bien en
tant que maire de calais cette
université
dont les antennes sont implantés à
boulogne calais dunkerque et saint-omer
a lancé en 2010 une école d'ingénieurs
l'école d'ingénieurs du littoral
cette structure à laquelle nous tenons
beaucoup compte 250 étudiants recrutés à
bac + 2 qui sortent avec le diplôme
d'ingénieur après trois années d'études
la carte universitaire est parfois
critiqué quand elle semble répondre à
des critères plus politique qu'à
l'intérêt des étudiants
mais l'existence d'université de
proximité est un atout indéniable quand
les formations sincère avantage de
mouvement dans le tissu économique
territoriale ainsi l'école d'ingénieurs
du littoral souhaite développer son
projet pédagogique sur les métiers des
flux de l'énergie ou de la mer qui sont
ceux de l'avenir de notre région
encourager ces cursus scientifique et
technique représente un véritable enjeu
pour renforcer l'économie locale tout en
offrant des débouchés à nos étudiants
ma question sur ce point sera double
d'une part nous souhaitons savoir
comment l'état peut accompagner la
montée en charge de ces filières alors
qu'elles sont adossés au budget des
universités de proximité
d'autre part comment encourager l'apport
de taxe d'apprentissage vers ces
formations dans les territoires en effet
quand l'initiative locale est forte
celle ci est concurrencé par les
métropoles régionales qui aspirent les
financements au sein de leur propre
région pouvait donc vous nous dire
madame la ministre nous indiquer quelle
est la politique du gouvernement pour
soutenir ces filières
merci madame la ministre la parole adam
la sénatrice me suis présenté la
médiatrice merci de cette question il se
trouve que je suis allé à boulogne et
que j'ai rencontré la communauté
universitaire ainsi que l'organisme de
recherche ifremer
en compagnie de frédéric l'huillier j'ai
pu voir à quel point les entreprises les
universités et laboratoires de cette
école d'ingénieurs travailler ensemble
dans des domaines très divers divers que
j'ai découvert d'ailleurs pas seulement
l'agroalimentaire mais pas seulement le
campus de la mer comme ils se sont
prénommés dents sur cette côte d'opale
c'est 4,6 de la côte d'opale mais
également dans le domaine des
cosmétiques
par exemple dans des communes dans des
domaines vraiment très divers il
travaille tout à fait naturellement avec
fluidité avec les entreprises c'est dire
que le partenariat avec les entreprises
via la taxe d'apprentissage doit pouvoir
se développer pour qu'ils puissent se
développer parce que cela contribuera
aussi à augmenter le nombre de jeunes en
alternance et vous savez que je crois
beaucoup à l'alternance pour la réussite
étudiante la réussite étudiante étant
d'ailleurs dans cette université de
proximité ulcos supérieur de 10 points
la réussite étudiante moyenne eh bien il
pouvoir se forme en apprentissage votre
université cette école d'ingénieurs de
se rapprocher d'un centre de formation
cfa d'un centre de formation d'apprentis
dans le nord pas de calais la plupart
des formations d'apprentissage dans
l'enseignement supérieur sont gérés par
le cfa formasup qu'à l'habitude de
travailler des organismes de formation
divers pour le reste et pour répondre à
l'augmentation des effectifs
eh bien il ya les contrats de sites et
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
la recherche aura à coeur de donner les
moyens nécessaires à cette université à
cette école d'ingénieurs pour pouvoir
continuer à insérer durablement dans le
territoire un bien insérés dans l'eure
dans cet écosystème qui a une dynamique
qui lui est propre et que j'ai pu encore
une fois constaté de visu de façon à
assurer la réussite étudiante et
l'insertion professionnelle des
étudiants concernés merci madame aux
sharks
oui donc si j'ai bien compris je peux
donc faire réponse donc à toutes ses
antennes qu'il y aura un contrat de site
et concernant la taxe d'apprentissage
par rapport aux métropoles y aurait-il
une possibilité d'avoir une pension sur
la ponction régional pour qu'elle
revienne un peu haute aux territoires
localement parce que elle aspire
beaucoup en fait de financement pour les
villes
centre de métropole merci la parole
l'état monsieur david assouline pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues votre
réforme a voulu prendre à bras le corps
avec les priorités clairement affirmée
la réussite étudiante et la réussite
étudiante on connaît le mal depuis
longtemps c'est ce taux d'échec
absolument énorme et indécent pour un
pays comme la france en premier cycle
or vous avez aussi brillant pris à bras
le corps dont votre réforme une des
raisons outre les mesures à prendre
au plan pédagogique de l'orientation qui
est manifestement les conditions de vie
matérielle et sociale de nos étudiants
et notamment de tous ceux qui sont parmi
les plus défavorisés qui ont dû déjà
pour arriver à l'université franchir un
certain nombre d'obstacles que leurs
conditions sociales a misé tout au long
de leur parcours scolaire et donc cette
cette question des conditions de vie
matérielle est une condition de la
réussite étudiante comment peut-on faire
quand on renonce à des soins un étudiant
sur trois parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
quand on est dans des logements ou
entassés en reste au domicile familial
sans possibilité de pouvoir réellement
étudié chez soi ou dans des habitats
précaires ou quand on est obligé de
travailler à mi temps parfois à plein
temps des petits boulots qui n'ont plus
rien à faire rien à voir avec les études
tout cela sont des situations auxquels
il faut faire face pour permettre la
réussite du plus grand nombre
alors nous savons que ça a été le parent
pauvre sous le précédent gouvernement
on n'essaie pas occupé de ça on a fait
une grande réforme on a négligé les cons
ces conditions de vie absolument
essentiel pour la réussite et je voulais
vous poser la question puisque vous avez
pris ce problème à bras le corps tant en
matière de bourse que deux logements
pour les étudiants que de santé
non seulement qu'est-ce qui est mise en
oeuvre au moment où deux millions
d'étudiants font leur rentrée
universitaire en ce moment et qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez déjà nous dire sur le
budget 2014 pour soutenir l'effort que
vous avez engagé madame la ministre
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur alors je
les dis la priorité de ce gouvernement
ce sont les étudiants
il ya aussi la recherche mais c'est un
autre sujet mais c'est vraiment la
réussite des étudiants qui dépend
beaucoup de leur environnement sa a été
dit donc nous avons pu dégager en trois
ans 400 millions d'euros en plus du
budget en plus du budget donc en plus du
budget augmenté de 2 2% de 2013 sur 2012
et de un pour cent sur de 2014 sur 2013
nous avons pu dégager 400 millions
d'euros comment se décompose style 150
millions d'euros en fin de gestion 2012
pour couvrir l'impasse du précédent
gouvernement fait sur le 10e mois de
bourse plus une revalorisation de
l'ensemble des échelon des boursiers de
2,1 pour cent la rentrée 2012 en 2013
nous avons revalorisé également les
bourses à hauteur de 150 millions
d'euros l'ensemble des bourses enfin 158
millions d'euros au budget 2014 ce qui
fait 457 millions d'euros exactement
plus de 400 millions d'euros dont 457
millions d'euros en trois ans nous avons
voulu sur les années 2013 et 2014
agir de façon qualitative nous l'avons
fait en concertation avec les étudiants
et nous avons visé les deux catégories
qui paraissaient les plus désavantagés
pour la réussite de leurs études liées à
leurs conditions de vie c'est le bas de
la classe moyenne on parle souvent de la
classe moyenne ben oui les jeunes qui
n'ont les familles n'avaient pas les
revenus suffisants donc devait être
aidée mais en même temps avait
suffisamment de revenus pour que
leurs jeunes ne bénéficie pas d'une
allocation mensuelle nous avons instauré
une allocation mensuelle de 100 euros
pour ces jeunes soit 1000 euros pendant
sur les 10 mois pourquoi ça leur évite
de travailler au delà de 15 heures parce
qu'au-delà 15 heures de travail en plus
de l'université on considère que l'on
compromet ses études nous avons fui
aussi viser les familles les plus
précaires et nous avons augmenté de 23%
et bourse de ces de ces jeunes nous
avons enfin viser les jeunes qui sont
désocialisées c'est à dire qu'ils sont
souvent épure familial et qui ont
bénéficié d'une allocation entre 4500 et
5500 euros
ils sont sept mille aujourd'hui donc au
total ce sont 100 mille jeunes qui sont
touchés par ces nouvelles bourses et
nous amplifierons fur et à mesure du
quinquennat ces aides jusque jusqu'à
arriver à une allocation d'autonomie
dernier point c'est la caution locative
elle concerne à titre expérimental de
1000 jeunes cette année vingt mille l'an
prochain avec une le soutien du crédit
coopératif du ministère l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et la caisse
des dépôts et consignations merci madame
la ministre monsieur assouline
oui je vous remercie pour votre réponse
qui est très concrète parce que ce
qu'ils avaient particulièrement choqué à
une époque mais c'étaient les campagnes
électorales qui voulait ça mais ceci dit
on avait choqué les jeunes c'était de
dire qu'on accorde un 10e mois de bourse
aux étudiants et que quand la gauche
arriver au pouvoir ce rendez compte
savait pas été provisionné et donc
c'était tout simplement un mensonge ou
que c'est vous nous donner des chiffres
les chiffres concrets des engagements un
budget je veux vous remercier pour cette
vérité mais vous alerter en même temps
sur un sujet puisque vous avez pris à
bras le corps le problème du
remboursement des frais d'inscription
pour les étudiants boursiers
c'est à la charge des universités cl en
tous les cas qui qui font l'opération et
il faudra faire attention à ce que les
et les universités qui accueille le plus
grand nombre d'étudiants boursiers ne
soient pas pénalisés par rapport aux
autres universités je pense que de ce
point de vue un effort de justice et
d'égalité à faire merci madame la
ministre
merci monsieur antiste vous avez la
parole pour le groupe socialiste
sur le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues ma question porte sur
les principaux enjeux auxquels doit
actuellement faire face université des
antilles de la guyane notamment ceux qui
concernent son attractivité en matière
de coopération nationale et
internationale mais aussi de recherche
en effet les universités ultramarines ne
pouvons connaître un véritable
changement d'échelle et accroître le
rayonnement qu'à condition d'élargir
leur périmètre d'influencé et de devenir
des acteurs majeurs de la zone
géographique à laquelle elles
appartiennent
c'est pourquoi il est nécessaire de
moderniser de renouveler l'offre de
formation en privilégiant les domaines
où l'usager peut apporter une plus-value
relation avec les besoins émergents sur
les territoires où elle est implantée
dans cette logique il faut encourager la
création de filières de formation
innovante et originale centrée sur les
spécificités locales comme la recherche
halieutique l'agroalimentaire le créole
ou encore la botanique médicinales il a
en outre indispensable madame la
ministre de permettre une meilleure
insertion de l'ue âgées dans les reese
dans les réseaux nationaux et
internationaux
deux mesures prioritaires peuvent être
envisagées afin d'améliorer la situation
étendre le coefficient correcteur aux
surcoûts occasionnés par les
déplacements de accompagné lui âgé dans
sa volonté de développer des masters
conjoints adossés à des unités de
recherche impliqués dans des programmes
collaboratifs avec les universités
appartenant à leur environnement
par ailleurs je souhaite évoquer
l'application de la loi le sr et plus
particulièrement le contenu de la
nouvelle ordonnance pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas de calendrier
allons-nous par exemple conserver les
acquis de l'ordonance de 2008 comme le
principe de la représentation paritaire
au sein des trois conseils sachant que
son application est quasi impossible
dans certains cas l'insuffisance de
viviez il est donc crucial d'établir une
large concertation entre les différents
acteurs concernés universités
d'outre-mer ministère de l'enseignement
collectivités territoriales notamment
afin de réfléchir ensemble sur le
fonctionnement des universités
ultramarines
et déterminer les mesures concrètes à
mettre en oeuvre pour pallier la
difficulté de notre université
pour cela je propose la mise en place
d'une mission d'information sur la
situation des universités ultramarines
quelle est votre position adam la
ministe sur ces différents sujets merci
monsieur le sénateur et cher collègue
madame la ministre
deux petites minutes mais ce président
merci de me poser cette question sur
l'université antilles guyane qui comme
vous le savez est une université sur
trois sites mais qui est et je vous
remercie de l'avoir dit également en
correspondance avec les universités des
caraïbes et qui devrait sûrement
davantage développé d'ailleurs ses
partenariats avec ces universités du
caraïbes alors ces universités font font
l'objet de toute notre attention
pourquoi parce que dans le cadre à la
fois de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique de la préparation de la
transition énergétique
nous voulons davantage développer les
recherches et les formations dans le
domaine marin nous utilisons finalement
assez peu nos côtes et les dom-tom sont
extrêmement bien placé là dessus c'est
ce que mon collègue frédéric cuvillier
ministre de la mer entre autres
appellent la croissance bleue
j'aurais qu'il ya là tout un potentiel
de croissance de développement de vos
universités qui aujourd'hui est vraiment
insuffisant insuffisamment développée
donc tout cela doit se discuter dans le
cadre d'un contrat de site
alors il va se passer des choses dans
les mois qui viennent mais vous savez
que la loi a été promulguée le 22
juillet il ya un certain nombre de
décrets ressortis rapidement dans les
six mois et nous avons 18 mois en ce qui
concerne les dom tom pour parvenir à une
synergie à une coopération entre les
trois sites de l'université antilles
guyane
sachant que les relations parfois ont
besoin de beaucoup de discussions pour
converger donc nous allons commencer
dans les semaines qui viennent la
concertation sur place avec les
collectivités territoriales
naturellement mais surtout avec les
acteurs de l'université avec les
recteurs la rectrice qui sont sur place
de façon à avoir un projet collectif et
commun qui répondent aux besoins très
importants des jeunes des dom-tom là où
le chômage est plus important les
besoins en qualification sont importants
et
tout cela doit se faire je les dis dans
l'optique d'un développement durable et
partagée car nous devons davantage
utiliser les potentialités de ces
territoires d'outre-mer qu'aujourd'hui
nous ne considérons pas suffisamment
comme d aider des facteurs de
développement donc nous serons bien au
rendez vous monsieur le sénateur et
j'espère bien pouvoir compter également
sur votre contribution
merci chers collègues vous avez la
parole oui je veux bien prendre note et
ne pas me tromper je retiens que vous
venez de vous engager à vous avez
reconnu l'éclatement de cette université
en trois morceaux et que vous venez de
promettre que vous aurez donc trois fois
plus d'attention les trois fois plus de
moyens pour notre université
mais si lecture positive du travail
sénatorial madame la milice mais chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance à
sera reprise à 16h pour l'examen de la
proposition de loi tendant au traitement
équilibré des territoires là vous venez
de suivre en direct de l'hémicycle la
séance de questions cribles des
questions cribles consacré à la rentrée
universitaire prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité sur public sénat 24 ans elle
a présenté par delphine girard